vielen dank in arbeit das ja wir sind
nicht im reichstagsgebäude sondern wir
sind im paul-löbe-haus wir sind
unmittelbar neben dem eingang des
europasaal sodann in einer guten stunde
nach etwas mehr ist es sogar die
bundeskanzlerin befragt werden wird im
wirecard untersuchungsausschuss der wie
es in den vergangenen tagen ja häufig
auch zu hören gewesen ist auf die
sogenannte zielgerade geht vor wenigen
minuten habe ich gelernt dass die
bundeskanzlerin nicht die letzte zeugin
ist die der untersuchungsausschuss
befragt sondern dass noch einige weitere
kommen in den kommenden wochen so
furchtbar viel zeit hat der ausschuss ja
nicht mehr muss irgendwann die befragung
beenden und dann auch einen bericht
schreiben und dann auch zu einem
ergebnis kommen zu einer bilanz
insgesamt also da dränge die zeit
durchaus ein wenig wir wollen
tatsächlich gucken auf das was heute von
der bundeskanzlerin gefragt wird oder
was die abgeordneten von mir wissen
wollen wollen aber ein bisschen zurück
gucken auf die bisherige arbeit dieses
untersuchungsausschusses nicht zuletzt
auf die befragung des
bundesfinanzministers gestern und in
arbeit das hat deswegen gesagt meine
damen und herren zwei gäste heute morgen
bei uns nämlich ein zimmermann der
obmann der spd fraktion in diesem
untersuchungsausschuss und fabio de masi
ist bei uns der obmann der linksfraktion
in diesem ausschuss bringen wir's mal
auf den punkt die bundeskanzlerin hat
weil während einer china-reise auch
geworden ist vielleicht fast schon ein
bisschen zu viel gesagt aber hat sich
eingesetzt heißt es für wirecard und
dass die firma geschäfte in china machen
kann was wollen sie wissen von ihr heute
konkret na ja sie hat schon also noch
konkreter kann man für ein unternehmen
im ausland nicht werben denn sie hat
sich dafür eingesetzt dass wirecard die
möglichkeit bekommt lizenzen in china zu
erwerben
und ja wir wollen vor allem wissen wie
ein café von karl theodor zu guttenberg
mit ihr gelaufen ist denn das wissen wir
mittlerweile karl theodor zu guttenberg
aber bei seiner alten chefin zu gast das
macht er anscheinend häufiger und hat
dort eben ganz konkret das thema
wirecard angesprochen dem
untersuchungsausschuss gegenüber hat er
bei seiner vernehmung gesagt er habe das
pro bono gemacht also quasi aus
freundschaft im unternehmen gegenüber
wir wissen mittlerweile
es hätten über zwei millionen euro für
sein unternehmen dabei rausspringen
können und wir wollen natürlich von der
kanzlerin wissen wie dieses gespräch
gelaufen ist hätte man sie welche
antworten erwarten sie von der kanzlerin
dazu bisher war die bundeskanzlerin sehr
schmallippig habe sie auch schon mal
offenen plenum gefragt da hat sie gesagt
wir würden das heute besprechen von
daher bin ich gespannt ob sie heute mehr
dazu sagt als die mir damals im plenum
gesagt hat aber es ist ja schon kurios
dass die kanzlerin sich beim mächtigsten
mann chinas ausgerechnet für wirecard
einsetzt weil es gibt ja viele andere
deutsche unternehmen die geschäfte in
china machen und ich vermute dass die
kanzlerin nicht über fünf zehn oder
zwanzig unternehmen in einem solchen
gespräch spricht sondern vielleicht über
zwei oder drei und weshalb war
ausgerechnet wirecard diese kriminelle
bude wie wir heute wissen so wichtig für
die kanzlerin
das sind berechtigte fragen was ist
bekannt zu diesem zeitpunkt was sie denn
tatsächlich und mit welchen empfehlungen
sie tatsächlich in china agiert hat na
ja wir wissen dass es da ein vermerk
gibt und es ist dann auch von ihrem chef
wirtschaftsberater ist an herrn zu
guttenberg per e-mail vollzug gemeldet
worden chefin hat das angesprochen und
das ist dann auch entsprechend gefeiert
worden und dieser wirtschaftsberater der
wird natürlich heute auch noch eine
entscheidende rolle spielen
der hat auch ein eher kuriosen auftritt
gehabt weil er hat uns gesagt seine
ehefrau die ist von beruf hausfrau
das ist ein bisschen altbacken das ist
mir bei konservativen ja noch gewohnt
aber diese hausfrau ist sehr modern die
hat nämlich ein business nebenbei und
vermittelt in china wirtschaftskontakte
unter anderem für wirecard gleichwohl
hätte würde man ja doch wahrscheinlich
von repräsentanten der bundesrepublik
erwarten dass sie für deutsche firmen im
ausland generell doch durchaus werben
weil die würden ja exportgeschäfte
machen wir auch die deutschen firmen
sollen im ausland ja durchaus aktiv sein
ja das ist auch nicht der vorwurf ich
kenne auch niemand der diesen vorwurf
grundsätzlich erhebt sondern die frage
ist ja hätte die bundesregierung
innerhalb acht stellung sein müssen weil
es eben von einer sehr renommierten
wirtschafts zeitung der financial times
und die puste sowas nicht einfach mal so
raus sehr schwere vorwürfe gegen
wirecard gab
es gab ja auch von finanzminister scholz
den deutsch chinesischen finanz dialog
im januar da waren diese vorwürfe
in diesen 20 19 verzeihung zu
orientieren
die sofort für noch nicht so konkret in
dieser art aber dann im weiteren
zeitlichen verlauf und deswegen glaube
ich auch greift die erklärung zu kurz
dass die bundeskanzlerin dort nur wegen
karl theodor karl theodor zu guttenberg
dem lothar matthäus der deutschen
politik vorbei spaziert ist weil es gab
er einen längeren vorlauf im rahmen des
deutsch-chinesischen finanziell lux man
wollte die chinesischen finanzmärkte für
deutsche unternehmen öffnen
aber man kann das nicht machen weil im
raum steht dass da ein riesiger geld
waschsalon am werk ist wie vorsichtig
hätte die bundeskanzlerin sein müssen
herr zimmermann damals
es ist sehr überraschend denn die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter im
kanzleramt die bahn schon sehr
vorsichtig als der der mittlerweile im
knast sitzende chef von wirecard herr
braun einen termin bei der kanzlerin
wollte und wir haben von frau dorothea
diese woche erfahren dass das irgendwie
seinen herzenswunsch war die kanzlerin
zu treffen haben die fachbeamten
abgewiegelt die haben zwar sehr höflich
gesagt aus termingründen aber wir haben
den vermerk gesehen da ist genau auf
diese kritische berichterstattung bezug
genommen worden
also man hat im kanzleramt das auf dem
schirm gehabt dass wirecard schon so ein
bisschen ein schmuddelkind sein könnten
wenn sie sagen man hat das schon auf dem
schirm gehabt
auch im kanzleramt beispielsweise dass
da nicht alles sauber läuft oder sogar
schmutzige geschäfte möglicherweise
laufen bei wirecard wie viel
vorsichtiger hätte dann eigentlich das
bundesfinanzministerium sein müssen und
die bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht sich
gestern etwas milder gewesen mit den
ministern sind alle sind zwei dinge die
aufsicht das eine und die frage ob ich
aktives gläubigen betreiben noch mal was
anderes aber wenn ich mir das anschaue
diese ganzen diese ganzen
topmanager von wirecard die haben keine
tür ins finanzministerium setzen können
also auch herr cookies hat die termine
abgelehnt und ich glaube das ist schon
ein unterschied ob man offen ist für für
ein solches agieren und ist ja auch kein
zufall dass auf dieser bezahl liste auf
der lohnliste von wirecard standen
ausschließlich ehemalige unions
politiker aber gleichwohl hätte die spd
das spd geführte finanzministerium nicht
ein bisschen offensiver schauen müssen
und möglicherweise offensive maßnahmen
einleiten um zu überprüfen was denn
tatsächlich vorgeht bei wirecard oder
zumindest noch offensiver auf die bafin
prüfen lassen also wir sehen dass immer
wenn kritische presse berichte
erschienen sind gab es konkrete aufträge
dem nachzugehen und zu ermitteln der aus
meiner sicht wirkliche vorwurf ist ja
dass innerhalb der bafin und dann dieser
mittlerweile bekannten dpr der deutschen
prüfstelle für rechnungswesen
diese hinweise versandet sind weil man
sich 18 monate zur prüfung zeit genommen
hat also sprich man hat das gesehen man
hat es beauftragt und dann ist aber die
umsetzung komplett schief gelaufen und
deswegen stehen wir unter anderem heute
auch hier mit den fragen zum
finanzminister sind wir schon elegant
rüber gewechselt zu dem was wir gestern
neun stunden lang stattgefunden hat im
europasaal und dem
untersuchungsausschuss wirecard wie ist
ihre bilanz hätte maße der gestrigen
befragung also soweit kam es mir gar
nicht vor im vergleich zur anderen
befragung gegen die zeit überfallen und
ich habe es anders empfunden ich habe
sehr viel zugesehen
das tut mir sehr leid für sie ich weiß
das ist hier manchmal doch sehr
anstrengend werden ja sehr viele tage
und nächte zusammen verbracht nun der
finanzminister sagt er hat von wirecard
nicht wirklich etwas mitbekommen zu der
zeit als er dieses abkommen dieses
deutsch-chinesische abkommen verhandelt
hat ich habe gelernt
untersuchungsausschüssen vertrauen nicht
immer den minister und vertraue den
akten und aus den akten geht aus meiner
sicht sehr eindeutig vor dass wirecard
doch ein sehr großes anliegen waren dass
man das als ein verhandlungserfolg
betrachtet hat weil wirecard war das
erste ausländische unternehmen das
überhaupt im chinesischen finanzmarkt
eine grenzüberschreitende zahlungs
lizenz bekommen sollte
man findet hinweise in den akten da
steht dann große sache zwei oder drei
ausrufezeichen dahinter und wirecard hat
auch immer im monitoring der
fortschritte dieses finanz dialogs immer
eine ganz zentrale rolle gespielt
wir wissen auch dass der staatssekretär
von olaf scholz wolfgang schmidt noch im
auftrag von spitzberg partners also die
lobbyisten von herrn zu guttenberg in
einem brief gesendet hat an seinen
chinesischen finanz kollegen und damals
waren sozusagen diese vorwürfe schon
bekannt deswegen finde ich kann sich das
finanzministerium hier nicht einen
schmalen fuß machen aber mir geht es
nicht darum ob jetzt herr scholz über
wirecard in diesem treffen gesprochen
hat oder nicht aber das
finanzministerium war dort eng am ball
und es hat sogar nachgefragt ob dann
etwas unterschriftsreifes für die
kanzlerin bald vorlegen
und das sind dinge die da sagt alle
meine erfahrung da wusste der minister
schon was er da eigentlich macht wenn du
nach china fährt ich war schon bei der
verantwortung im finanzministerium
insgesamt so in meinen gedanken an
welcher stelle er den mars ii hat das
finanzministerium nachweislich politisch
falsch gehandelt in der angelegenheit
naja ich denke das finanzministerium
hätte zum beispiel beim
leerverkaufsverbot ein paar mehr
kritische fragen stellen müssen wenn man
dann hinterher doch mit bekommt da wird
eine wilde erpressung story der münchner
staatsanwaltschaft präsentiert die sagt
da würde blumenberg eine
nachrichtenagentur wirecard gemeinsam
mit der financial times erpressen wollen
und der kronzeuge ist ein britischer
drogendealer das konnte das findet das
ministerium nicht wissen aber sie
konnten wissen dass eine wilde
erpressungs geschichte dahinter steht
das haben sie ja auch später erfahren
und spätestens da hätte man meines
erachtens wirklich sagen dass eine
alarmstufe rot was ist da eigentlich los
und das ist deutlich zu entspannt
gelaufen hinzu kommt dass natürlich die
ganze situation in der finanzaufsicht ja
nicht erst seit dem wirecard skandal
bekannt ist wir hatten comex wir hatten
p und r
wir hatten jetzt wieder green sind also
wir hatten chronische strukturprobleme
in der finanzaufsicht und die hätte man
anpacken müssen wie hätte man vielleicht
aber auch schon früher anpacken müssen
ich bin ja auch nicht derjenige der das
nicht seit vier jahren permanent
thematisieren würde ich gehe da anderen
im finanzausschuss ordentlich auf die
nerven mit und deswegen fühle ich mich
jetzt hier gar nicht angesprochen
ich habe übrigens auch zu anfang 2009 10
die erste kritische parlamentarische
anfrage
wirecard gestellt ich bin ja kein genie
also wenn mir das aufgefallen ist da
stinkt was hätte das dem ministerium
auch auffallen können sollte sie auch
gar nicht angegriffen haben gottes
willen der verbots leerverkaufsverbote
so rum
es geht um wetten auf fallende
aktienkurse
wie ist ihre einschätzung der situation
damals zu diesem thema na ja da hat sich
dieser untersuchungsausschuss ja absolut
ausgezahlt weil wir mittlerweile wissen
was die umstände waren die umstände
waren das die bekannteste wirtschafts
staatsanwälte in deutschland selbst zum
telefonhörer gegriffen hat bei der bafin
angerufen hat und gesagt hat wirecard
wird erpresst so was habe ich in meinem
ganzen leben noch nicht gesehen und das
war der auslöser für einen fatalen
domino effekt weil und das hat auch
staatssekretär cookies gesagt wenn die
aufsicht auf grundlage von
staatsanwaltschaftlichen hinweisen tätig
wird dann werden wir mit dem klammer
sagt gepudert als politische ebene im
finanzministerium zu sagen nee nee nee
mach da mal langsam und das ich sag's
das ist wie gesagt hat eine fatale
kettenreaktion hervorgerufen weil am
ende alle gesagt kann naja wenn die
staatsanwaltschaft konkrete hinweise hat
das einerseits wirecard erpresst wird
und andererseits auf fallende kurse
gesetzt wird
dann müssen wir hier ein schreiben wir
wissen heute es war falsch
es ist eben teil und das darf man bei
diesen ganzen skandal nicht vergessen an
der spitze bandenmäßiger betrug diese
kriminelle energie des topmanagements
die waren sich nicht zu schade sich
eines renommierten anwalts in münchen zu
bedienen und der hat es dann geschafft
in einer episode von kleider machen
leute
die staatsanwaltschaft davon zu
überzeugen dass eben diese erpressung
existiert bemerkt eine der
bemerkenswertesten aussagen weil wir von
diesem ausschuss und ich gesehen habe
nämlich markus braun befragt wurde der
frühere chef von wirecard der glaube ich
sogar aufsichtsbehörden in schutz
genommen hatte oder auch ministerium und
gesagt hat irgendwie ja das konnten wir
gar nicht mitkriegen weil wir ja mal
systematisch das sind jetzt meine worte
wir haben halt systematisch belogen und
betrogen
unter dem großzügig von markus braun
aber ich würde ihnen nicht unbedingt als
entlastungszeugen für irgendjemand sehen
wir haben leider keine neun stunden so
wie sie gestern im ausschuss und heute
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so
lang gehen aber trotzdem wollen wir ganz
auf die schnelle vielleicht noch mal
gucken eine bilanz dieses
untersuchungsausschusses auch wenn
einige zeugenbefragung noch kommen wie
würden welche bieten sie ziehen hätte
sie ich glaube das ist ein großer
fraktionsübergreifender erfolg wir
konnten sehr viele dinge aufhellen
ich glaube sind auch noch nie in so
kurzer zeit so viele köpfe gerollt das
ist nicht das ziel eines ausschusses
wir sind nicht bei der französischen
revolution wir sind auch kein gericht
aber wir machen eine öffentliche
tatortbegehung damit sich die menschen
ein urteil bilden können
der kollege zimmermann hat das
angesprochen wir haben die arbeit der
staatsanwaltschaft auch beleuchtet die
übrigens auch herrn marschalek heraus
spazieren lassen als die 1,9 milliarden
euro auf den philippinen weg waren wir
haben uns mit dem insiderhandel
beschäftigt in aufsichtsbehörden ich
denke wir konnten hier wirklich auch ein
stück weit auch den kleinanlegern
kleinanzeigen auch in zeiten von masken
dieses vom selbstbereicherung von vielen
abgeordneten gibt es die abgeordneten
die noch ihren job machen aufsicht und
kontrolle sind dringlich nur zu regeln
das ist glaube ich auch ein ganz
wesentliches merkmal dessen was sie
herausgefunden haben auch die
zuständigkeiten für bestimmte bereiche
auch die einstufung von konzernen
wirecard damit man dann die
zuständigkeit regeln kann was denken sie
wie schnell wird es kommen dass das was
beispielsweise der finanzminister
vorgeschlagen hat an maßnahmen die das
verändern sollen
wie lange wird es noch brauchen das
gesetz ist ja schon den bundestag
eingebracht und ich glaube auch dieser
untersuchungsausschuss hat dazu
beigetragen dass auch unser
koalitionspartner da jetzt ein bisschen
tempo an den tag legen muss weil die
haben gesagt ja gründlich aufklären also
eher so ein bisschen schieben
aber wir haben natürlich noch einen
weiteren aspekt die wirtschaftsprüfer
weil wir sind hier rein gestartet als
finanzskandal und mittlerweile ist es
eigentlich ein wirtschaftsprüfung
skandal auch geworden und das sind im
übrigen auch vor allem die zeugen die
wir noch hören werden
das wird für ein großes deutsches
wirtschaftsprüfungsunternehmen hier noch
ziemlich hart werden erzähl mal in
vielen dank auch ebene sie vielen dank
dass ihr heute morgen bei uns gewesen
sind die sitzung beginnt ungefähr gegen
zehn hängt ein bisschen davon ab wie das
mit einer abstimmung im bundestag heute
vor
man geht und wie es vorangeht sagt den
jetzt jeanette klag rüber ins
reichstagsgebäude